[موسيقى]
مساء الخير فجاه اصبحت النيجر التي لا
يعرف الكثير منا اين هي حديث الساعه
وتحديدا منذ ان وقع انقلاب هناك في 26
يوليو الماضي منذ ذلك التاريخ قامت الدنيا
ولم تقعد سارع الدول الغربيه بفرض عقوبات
لم تكتفل اكواس او دول تكتل غرب افريقيا
بالعقوبات بل هددت مدعومه من الغرب بعمل
عسكري اذا لم يتراجع العسكريون عن
انقلابهم بحلول سته اغسطس الجاري اليوم
انا بسجل الحلقه يوم
ظهر يوم 6 اغسطس اي مع انتهاء المهله التي
منحت للعسكريين
قبل انتهاء المهله اصلا بيوم واحد اعلنت
دول الاكواس عن اكتمال الخطط العسكريه
للتدخل المحتمل في النيجر دون تحديد موعد
لهذه العمليه التي يمكن ان تندلع في اي
لحظه اذا لم تحدث مفاجات
بيتزعم دول الاقواس نيجيريا اللي هي اكبر
دول افريقيا
نيجيريا المجاوره لدوله النيجر قررت ايضا
قطع الوقود الذي يغذي محطات الكهرباء في
مدن وقرى النيجر في مواجهه ما يجري تصلب
المنقلبون واعلنوا استعدادهم لاسوء
الاحتمالات
وتضامن مع النيجر ثلاثه دول رئيسه مجاوره
بوركينا فاسو ومالي وغينيا بوركينا فاسو
ومالي تحديدا اعتبروا ان اي هجوم على
النيجر هو اعلان حرب عليهما ليه ببساطه
لان بوركينا فاسو ومالي وايضا معهم غينيا
مغضوب عليهم من دول الاقواس ومن حلفائهم
الغربيين لان الحكومات الثلاثه في هذه
الدول جاءت بانقلابات مماثله لما حدث في
النيجر في السنوات القليله الماضيه مصادر
كشفت مؤخرا انه
سلطه الانقلاب في النيجر تواصلت مع جماعه
فاجنر الروسيه لتطلب مساعدتها في التصدي
للهجوم المحتمل من دول الاكواس انقسمت دول
العالم بين فريق يؤير تغيير الوضع في
النيجر بالقوه وفريق يدعم الانقلاب او على
الاقل يرفض التدخل العسكري ضده اسئله
كثيره لماذا كل هذه الضجه على انقلاب في
بلد شهد اربع انقلابات سابقه منذ استقلاله
عن فرنسا عام 1960 ولم ينعم بانتقال سلمي
للسلطه الا مره واحده في تاريخه والنيجر
دي جزء من منطقه الساحل اللي شهدت ست
انقلابات في السنوات الثلاثه الاخيره
بالاضافه لانقلاب سابع في غينيا المجاوره
والساحل كله على بعضه جزء من افريقيا اللي
شاهدت 98 انقلاب الناجحا منذ عام 1952
والى الان المقصود بناجح ان المنقلبين
نجحوا في الوصول الى السلطه اما محاولات
الانقلاب الفاشله فهي اضعاف هذا الرقم اذا
لماذا كل هذه الضجه والشعور بالصدمه وكان
الانقلاب وقع في برلين وليس داخل النيجر
التي تقع في قاره بات الانقلاب فيها وسيله
معتاده لنقل السلطه الاجابه على هذا
السؤال تقتدي خلفيه جغرافيه وتاريخيه
وسياسيه سريعه بدايه الف به نيجر نيجر دي
واحده من افقر بلدان العالم عدد سكانها
حوالي 27 مليون نسمه مساحتها كبيره الى حد
ما بتتكلم على مليون
و266 الف كيلو متر مربع تقريبا يعني
بتعادل مساحه مصر وسوريا والاردن تقريبا
ناتجها المحلي
متواضع جدا بنتكلم على حوالي 15 مليار
دولار فقط لا غير لكن اهميه النيجر مرتبطه
بكونها تقع في منطقه الساحل الافريقي لكن
اين هي منطقه الساحل الافريقي اصلا الساحل
منطقه لها اكثر من تعريف جغرافيا هي
المنطقه اللي بتمتد من سواحل السنغال
وموريتانيا غربا على المحيط الاطلنطي الى
سواحل اريتريا والسودان شرقا على البحر
الاحمر يعني لو تخيلت الخريطه هتجد في
افريقيا في دول شمال افريقيا المعروفه
اللي بتبدا من مصر
شرقا الى المغرب غربا تحت هذه الدول
مباشره مجموعه دول بيطلق عليها منطقه
الساحل بتمتد من سواحل المحيط الاطلنطي
الى سواحل البحر الاحمر بهذا التعريف
منطقه الساحل بتضم عشر دول بتمتد طولا على
مساحه اقل قليلا من 6000 كيلو متر من
المحيط الاطلنطي للبحر الاحمر
هذه الدول هي مره تانيه السنغال موريتانيا
مالي النيجر تشاد السودان اريتريا الدول
السبعه دول بيقعوا اما بكاملهم او بمعظمهم
في منطقه الساحل الجغرافيه ويضاف اليهم
ثلاث دول اخرى بيقع جزء صغير منها في
منطقه الساحل لكن بتحسب على منطقه الساحل
الدول التلاته بوركينا فاسو ونيجيريا بيقع
اقصى حدودها الشماليه في الساحل وكذلك
الجزائر اللي بتقع اقصى حدودها الجنوبيه
في هذه المنطقه لكن سياسيا عاده ما ينصرف
الذهن عند ذكر كلمه منطقه الساحل الى خمس
دول هي مالي والنيجر وبوركينا فاسو وتشاد
وموريتانيا وبتسمى بدول الساحل الخمس
مؤخرا ضاقت التعريف لانصرف الى ثلاث دول
فقط هي مالي وبوركينا فاس والنيجر او ما
يسمى بمنطقه الساحل الوسطى او المركزيه
ببساطه لانها اصبحت الدول الاكثر وخطوره
منطقه الساحل بالتعريفات الثلاثه هي محل
اهتمام الدول الكبرى لثلاثه اسباب رئيسه
وتقدر تشيل كلمه ثلاثه اسباب وتقول بسبب
الصادرات الثلاثه الرئيسه لهذه الدول ماذا
تصدر مناطق الساحل او دول الساحل للعالم
تلاته موارد طبيعيه خام مهاجرين غير
شرعيين ولاجئين
وارهابيين ومتطرفين مزيدا من التفاصيل
الدول الكبيره مهتمه بمنطقه الساحل
بتعريفاتها الثلاثه لعده اسباب السبب
الاول هو السيطره على مواردها الطبيعيه
بارخص الاسعار نيجيريا مثلا هي واحده من
اكبر من تيجي اليورانيوم في العالم ومورد
رئيسي له لاوروبا وخصوصا فرنسا وطبعا
اليورانيوم ده هو عصب الطاقه النوويه في
العالم
اثنين الدول الكبيره بتحاول بتواجدها هناك
السيطره على طرق الهجره غير الشرعيه
المتجهه الى اوروبا ايه
القصه انه هذه المنطقه الفقيره اللي
بتعاني من فراغ امني وضعف الحكومات
المركزيه بتعاني في نفس الوقت من تزايد
كبير جدا في عدد السكان بشكل منفرد مع
اثار خطيره للتغير المناخي ادت الى شرح
الاراضي وشح المياه وشح الاراضي مع شح
المياه مع تزايد عدد السكان خلق منافسه
صفريه بين الاهالي في هذه الدول على
الاراضي والموارد يعني يا اما هذه الارض
ليا يا اما لك يا اما هذا المرء عليه يا
اما هذا المرعى لك
الاراضي والموارد لا تتسع لك الينا
وبالتالي بدات القبائل يحارب بعضها بعضا
العشائر الناس يستو كل منهم على الاخر
والنتيجه الطبيعيه موجات من الهجره
واللجوء في اتجاه اوروبا والغرب عبر دول
شمال افريقيا ليبيا وتونس والجزائر وده
بنتابع اخباره كل يوم على القنوات
التليفزيونيه
السبب الثالث لاهتمام الدول الكبيره بهذه
المنطقه من العالم هي محاوله هذه الدول
ضرب الجماعات المتطرفه التي تسيطر على
اجزاء كبيره من منطقه الساحل ومنطقه
الساحل في السنوات الاخيره اصبحت صاحبه
لقب اكبر بؤره للارهاب في العالم او اكبر
بؤره لما يسمى بالجهاد العالمي رابعا
اكتسبت دول الساحل اهميه متزايده بعد حرب
اوكرانيا ومحاوله روسيا الضغط على مصالح
الدول الغربيه هناك بل وطرد الغرب من هذه
الدول باكتداب هذه الدول الافريقيه الى
موسكو
سيطره روسيا على هذه الدول بيحرم الغرب من
كل المزايا السابقه يعني الموارد الطبيعيه
مثلا ويمنح الروس القدره على تهديد اوروبا
بفتح ممرات الهجره والارهاب اليها
اضف الى كل الاسباب السابقه اعتبارات مهمه
دول الساحل رغم فقرها هي اسواق لمنتجات
هذه الدول الغنيه قواعد عسكريه لجيوشها
مواقع متقدمه لسياساتها الخارجيه يعني
وجود فرنسا او روسيا في منطقه الساحل
احيانا بيبقى الهدف منه لا يتعلق بالساحل
ولكن يتعلق بمحاوله اكتساب نفوذ او ممارسه
ضغوط على دول اخرى في شمال القاره في
جنوبها في غربها لانه الساحل دي منطقه
بتتوسط القاره كلها لكن في السنوات
الاخيره باتت محاربه الارهاب هناك السبب
الاكثر الحاحا للاهتمام بدول الساحل
تقرير الارهاب العالمي اللي هو بيصدر
سنويا عن معهد الاقتصاد والسلام واللي صدر
في مارس 2023 بيقول ببساطه كده منطقه
الساحل اصبحت بؤره الارهاب الاكبر في
العالم وهذا التقرير وتقارير اخرى كثيره
بتدلل على هذه الحقائق او على هذه الحقيقه
بمجموعه كبيره من الارقام انا قدامي ارقام
كثيره مفزعه على مدى تغول وتوغل
الارهاب والتطرف في هذه المنطقه من العالم
اكتفي بعدد محدود من الارقام اختصارا
للوقت على سبيل المثال سجلت منطقه الساحل
اكبر عدد من ضحايا الارهاب في العالم في
عام 2022
عدد من قتل في منطقه الساحل على ايدي
الارهاب يمثل 43% من اجمالي عدد الضحايا
على ايدي الارهابيين في العالم كله
لاحظوا بقى 43% ممن قتل على يد الارهابيين
قطره في منطقه الساحل قرن هذا الرقم
بما حدث في 2007 2007 كان نصيب هذه الدول
من ضحايا الارهاب بيمثل واحد في المئه فقط
من كل من قتل على يد ارهابيين حول العالم
2007 واحد في الميه 2022 43%
نشاط الجامعات الاسلاميه المسلحه في هذه
الدول اللي هي دول الساحل بالتعريف اللي
انا قلت لحضراتكم عليه هو جزء من انتشارهم
في قاره افريقيا كلها وفي قاره افريقيا
كلها هناك توحش للتطرف والارهاب او ذبحيات
مئه الف شخص من 2014 الى الان احنا بنتكلم
على منطقه الساحل بنتكلم على افريقيا لكن
في حقيقه الامر ان المشكله بتتركز تقريبا
في ثلاث دول رئيسه هي مالي وبوركينا فاسو
والنيجر عشان كده بقت هي الدول الثلاثه
اللي بتحظى بالاهتمام الاكبر لما بنتكلم
على الارهاب او لما بنتكلم على منطقه
الساحل على سبيل المثال في السنوات العشره
الماضيه قتلت 42 الف شخص في هذه الدول
الثلاث وفر من هذه الدول ثلاثه وثلاثه من
عشره مليون شخص من منازلهم بسبب الفوضى
وسي طره الارهابيين على مساحات واسعه في
هذه الدول
بوركينا فاسو تحديدا وهي دوله مجاوره
للنيجر اصبحت بتحتل المركز الثاني عالميا
من حيث عدد ضحايا الارهاب الدوله الاولى
هي افغانستان وفقا لتقرير
مؤشرات الارهاب العالمي
شديد لا يوجد جهاز مكافحه ارهاب واحد في
العالم الا ويتابع يوما بيوم ما يجري في
منطقه الساحل لانها اصبحت اكبر بؤره
للارهاب في العالم
قال اللي بيطرح نفسه لماذا اصبحت هذه
المنطقه هي الاكثر
ايه الاشياء اللي يعني كان ابو بكر بيتكلم
عليها باعتبارها متاع الدنيا الاربع اشياء
المال النساء اللحوم دراجه بخاريه ما قالش
يعني حاجات كبيره قوي ما يعني ان الحديث
عن الكفاح المقدس لبناء دوله الخلافه
شعارات لا معنى لها لكثير من هؤلاء الشباب
الفقير الذي وجد ان نهب الاخرين باسم
الدين اكثر ربحا من الوظائف القليله
المتاحه حكايه نهب الاخرين دي ما هذه
الجماعات بتشكل عصابات اجراميه بتسطو على
قبائل بتسطو على قرى بالكامل بتحرقها
بتقتل رجلها بتسرق ممتلكاتهم بتغتصب
نسائهم باعتبار ان اموالهم ونسائهم حلوا
لهم طب ليه الجماعات دي اما لانها مناصره
للدوله الكافره او لانهم بيعترقوا اديانا
اخرى غير الاسلام وهكذا
لكل هذه الاسباب بتتواجد دول غربيه كبيره
على راسها فرنسا والولايات المتحده في هذه
المنطقه لكن تواجد هذه الدول بيتطلب
علاقات وثيقه مع انظمه الحكم
الموجوده هناك حدث متغير كبير اقلق الغرب
مؤخرا سلسله انقلابات متعاقبه على الانظمه
المدعومه من الغرب يعني في منطقه الساحه
الخمس انقلابات في ثلاث سنوات مالي
وبوركينا فاسو اخيرا النيجر
الجنرالات بيبرروا هذه الانقلابات بعجز
الحكومات المدنيه عن مواجهه الجامعات
الاسلاميه المسلحه بالاضافه للسخط العام
عند المواطنين على سوق الاحوال لكن خصومهم
بيقولوا هذا ليس صحيحا مصالحهم الشخصيه
ورغبتهم في السلطه هي السبب ثم انهم عندما
جاءوا الى السلطه في بوركينا فاسو مثلا في
قنافسه او مالي مثلا لم ينجحوا فيما فشلت
فيه الحكومات المدنيه والفشل على كل حال
متوقع لان الحلول الامنيه مطلوبه لكن
وحدها لا تكفي التنميه التعليم تاسيس دوله
قانون اهم لكن هذه اهداف تحقيقها عاوز
رؤيه عاوز امكانيات عاوز وهذه الرؤيه
والالتزام لا موجود لدى
الجماعات او
الجنرالات المنقلبين ولا لدى الدول
الغربيه اللي عاوزه تستفيد بقدر الامكان
من هذه الدول دون ان تبذل جهدا كبيرا في
تنميتها في تقدير في سبب اخر ان الجنرالات
ينقلبون على رؤسائهم لانهم يستطيعون ان
يفعلوا ذلك ببساطه في اطار دوله ضعيفه
الطموح وحب السلطه وعدم الرضا عن حكومه ما
موجود في كثير من دول العالم لكن الفرق ان
في دول الساحل يستطيع الجنرال ببساطه ان
يحتجز رئيس الدوله ويخرج ليعلن على
التلفزيون تشكيل مجلس عسكري انتقالي
لانقاذ البلاد من الفوضى والفساد والمجلس
الانتقالي يظل في السلطه الى ان يطيح به
جنرال اخر
في هذا الاطار جاء انقلاب النيجر لكن
الاطاحه
بالرئيس محمد بازوم في 26 يوليو الماضي
وهو تولى منصبه على كل الاحوال في 2021 في
اول انتبهوا في اول انتقال ديمقراطي
للسلطه في تاريخها هذا الانقلاب عليه فجر
ازمه غير مسبوقه ادهشت المنقلبين اكثر من
غيرهم ليش معنى احنا يعني الدنيا كلها
قامت علينا ما غيرنا كثيرا انقلب على
رؤسائه الواضح ان في مجموعه اسباب ادت الى
كل هذا الاهتمام وكل هذه الضجه حول انقلاب
النيجر السبب الاولاني صحيح الانقلابات
عموما ليست جديده على منطقه الساحل ولا
افريقيا بل هي طريقه شبه معتاده لانتقال
السلطه هناك لكن وتيره هذه الانقلابات
تراجعت في افريقيا الى ادنى مستوى لها في
السنوات ما بين 2007 ل 2017 الغريب ان هذه
الفتره السنوات العشره من 2017 كانت فتره
الربيع العربي اي فتره اشتعال العالم
العربي وشمال افريقيا المجاور لمنطقه
الساحل اشتعال في العالم العربي وهدوء
نسبيون في افريقيا هذا الهدوء عزز الامال
بانتهاء ظاهره الانقلابات الشهيره في
افريقيا لكن سرعان ما عادت مره اخرى وبشكل
وبائي يعني ايه بشكل وبائي سريعه جدا
كثيره جدا مالي حدث فيها انقلبين في تسع
شهور الاول في 18 اغسطس 2020 نفس الجنرال
اللي انقلب في هذا التاريخ شكل حكومه او
مجلس مدني تحت ضغط المجتمع الدولي ثم عاد
لينقلب عليه في 24 مايو 2021
بوركينا فاسو شهدت انقلابين في ثمان شهور
الاول في 24 يناير 22 والثاني في 30
سبتمبر 2022 عدد
انقلابات يرتفع الى ثمانيه الى اخذنا
الدول المجاوره السودان وتشاد وغينيا
السبب الثاني الخوف من العدوى تسارع
الانقلابات في منطقه ما كثير ما يكونوا
ناتجا عن عدوى ده مش انا اللي بقول ده
الدراسات السياسيه جنرال يرى زملائه نجحوا
في دوله المجاوره في الاطاحه بالحكومه
المدنيه فيقول لماذا لا انتقل من مواقع
العساكر الى يعني مصاف قاده الدول
وبالتالي ده بيشجعه على الاطاحه برؤسائه
ما يعني ان دائره الانقلابات قد تتسع
يتسعت بالفعل الان في الوقت الحالي هناك
ست دول متجاوره بتحكمها انظمه انقلابيه في
هذه المنطقه من العالم
الانظمه الانقلابيه دي موجوده في غينيا
ومالي وبوركينا فاسو والنيجر وتشاد
والسودان فيما يمكن ان يسمى بحزام
الانقلابات في افريقيا هذا الحزام بيمتد
لمسافه تصل الى 5600 كيلو مترا تقريبا وهو
بذلك اطول ممر او الشريط متصل للحكم
العسكري على وجه الارض الان
السبب الثالث ان النيجر هي اخر معقل
للقوات الغربيه وخاصه فرنسا في دول الساحل
اللي سقطت تحت حكم عسكريين فقدوا الاهتمام
والثقه في التعامل مع الغرب وبعضهم فضل
التوجه الى روسيا من وجهه نظر امريكيه
وغربيه النيجر كانت جزيره استقرار نسبه
طبعا في منطقه تزداد فيها الفوضى وكانت
النيجر عامل محوري في عمليات مكافحه
الارهاب الغربيه في منطقه الساحل حتى هذه
اللحظه النيجر مقر لقاعدتين عسكريتين
واحده لامريكا والاخرى لفرنسا فرنسا عندها
1500 جندي
والولايات المتحده عندها 1100 جندي والالف
ومئه جندي الامريكان دول بيعملوا في اكبر
قاعده امريكيه في افريقيا للدرونز او
الطائرات المسيره اللي بتستخدم بشكل اساسي
لمكافحه الارهاب في كامل دوله افريقيا
لذلك كان الانقلاب العسكري في النيجر
الصدمه الى هذه الدول افتح قوسين كبار جدا
احد اهم دوافع فرنسا في
معارضه الانقلاب الاخير في النيجر انها في
حقيقه الامر تدافع عن بقائها الذي بات
مهددا في افريقيا كلها وافريقيا دي احد
اهم معاقل نفوذ فرنسا تاريخيا منطقه غرب
ووسط افريقيا تحديدا كانت منطقه نفوذ
خالصه لفرنسا منذ ان انهت استعمارها لهذه
الدول او لمعظم هذه الدول في الستينات لكن
هذا النفوذ بيتراجع بشده في السنوات
الاخيره بدات المتاعب من مالي اللي اتطرد
حكامها العسكريون 5000 جندي فرنسي العام
الماضي 2022
الخمس الاف جندي دول كانوا متواجدين من
2013 تحت حجه مقاومه الانفصاليين
والارهابيين
وحكام مالي الجدد استعانوا بفاجنر الروسيه
لدعم حربهم على الجامعات الاسلاميه
والانفصاليه اضطرت فرنسا ايضا لسحب قواتها
من بوركينا فاسو المجاوره هذا العام بناء
على طلب الحكومه العسكريه الجديده للبلاد
وسبق لفرنسا ان خرجت بشكل مهين من دوله
مجاوره وهي جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى ايضا
لصالح الروس اللي بيته يسيطرون على هذه
الدوله فضلا عن موجه متصاعده من المشاعر
المعاديه في دول اخرى كثيره في القاره ليه
قصه طويله لكن باختصار الشعور السائد ان
فرنسا دوله مستعمره نهبت وتنهب ثرواتهم
ولن تحقق لهم بتواجدها شيئا لا امن ولا
تنميه بعد خروجها من مالي وبوركينا فاسو
تحديدا زادت اهميه النيجر لفرنسا اخر
معاقله في منطقه الساحل الوسطى لكن جاء
انقلب 26 يوليو لي يوجه ضربه جديده
للفرنسيين مشهد هجوم الجماهير على مبنى
سفارتها في النيجر يوم 30 يوليو 2023
واحتفالهم برفع اعلام روسيا عبر بشكل واضح
جدا عن تراجع ومازق فرنسا في هذه المنطقه
الحيويه لباريس
السبب الرابع
للاهتمام الدولي بما جرى في النيجر وخشيت
دول الاكواس او تكتل دول غرب افريقيا
المكون من 15 عضوا من انتقال العدوى اليها
عدوى ايه عدوتين عدوى الانقلابات لبلدانها
خصوصا بعد ان حدث انقلاب داخل احد اعضائها
وهي غينيا في سبتمبر 2021
ومع الانقلاب ايضا يخشون من عدوى من عدوى
الفوضى
والتطرف الديني ثم ان رئيس النيجر
بول تيمبو له مواقف متشدده من الانقلابات
لانه كان سجن لفتره في عام 1994 من قبل
حاكم عسكري ومنذ هذه الفتره جعل الرئيس
النيجيري الحالي ورئيس مجموعه الاقواس
معارضه الانقلابات حجر الزاويه في سياسه
الخارجيه وتعهد كده هو مجموعه الاقواس
بمحاربه الانقلابات في كل مكان اصبح
التزاما وعندما انتخب لهذه المجموعه كان
دائما يكرر لن نسمح بانقلاب بعد انقلاب
الاكواس كمان عندها نوع من الثقه في
قدرتها على مواجهه ما يجري في النيجر لان
عندها تجارب سابقه لاقى بعضها النجاح هي
مؤسسه جناح عسكري لها مجموعه الاكواس سنه
90 ومنذ سنه 90 الى الان تدخلت في تسع في
سبع نزاعات في دول مجاوره معظم هذه
النزاعات يا حروب اهليه هي محاولات انقلاب
وطبعا تدخلها ده كان بدرجات مختلفه من
النجاح لكن اخرها كان جنبي في عام 2017
حين اجبرت رئيس غامبيا السابق يحيى جامع
الخاسر في الانتخابات على القبول بنتائج
الانتخابات لكل هذه الاسباب تحددت الاكواس
بعمل عسكري اذا لم تتم اعاده محمد بازوم
الى منصبه بحلول السادس من اغسطس الجاري
وبدرت بفرض عقوبات على النيجر واغلقت
وعلقت جميع المعاملات بين النيجر ودول
المجموعه وجماده اصول النيجر في البنوك
المركزيه النيجر دوله حبيسه بالمناسبه
وباتت تقريبا تحت حصار فرنسا بريطانيا
امريكا دول اخرى نعمه الاكواس بدرجات
مختلفه فرنسا هي الاكثر تشددا للاسباب
اللي انا شرحتها امريكا متردده الى حد ما
على سبيل المثال لم تعلن اداره بيضا حتى
الان رسميا ان الاستيلاء على السلطه في
النيجر وانقلاب ليه هو انقلاب طبعا لكن
لانه هي اذا اعتبرت دار رسميا انقلاب سوف
يفرض القانون عليها تجميد المساعدات
العسكريه للنخب الحاكمه الان في النيجر
تجميد هذه المساعدات يعني زياده قوه
الجماعات المتطرفه ويترتب على ذلك تقارب
محتمل بين النخب العسكريه وجماعه فاجنر
اللي بتقدم نفسها كبديل للغرب في امريكا
مش عارفه تعمل ايه في ورطه انما
يعني برضو هي بتدين ما يجري هناك الان
العالم منقسم بين فريقين
فريق يدعم التدخل العسكري دعما للشرعيه
ومنعا وردعا لمزيد من الانقلابات هذا
المعسكر اللي بتقوده الاقواس مدعومه من
الغرب وخاصه فرنسا طبعا عندها مصالحها
الخاصه جدا كما هو واضح جدا في حاله فرنسا
ولكن هناك دفع اخر وهو الخوف من تنامي
التطرف والهجره غير الشرعيه اذا هم تركوا
هذه البلدان لحالها التي فشلوا ان يقيموا
عليها حكومات مستقره ويواجهوا الارهاب
فيها فان الارهاب لن يتركهم لن يترك هذه
الدول الارهاب بيتسلل عبر حدود الدول
ويهدد اكبر اقتصادات في افريقيا لكن
المساله لا تقتصر على افريقيا الجيش
الامريكي
اكبر مسؤول عسكري امريكي في افريقيا اعلن
مؤخرا بانه هناك تنامي خطير للجامعات
المتطرفه على المصالح الامريكيه وان هذا
هذه الجامعات سوف تهدد الامريكان
والمواطنين الامريكان والسفارات الامريكيه
في افريقيا وليس من المستبعد ابدا ان
يهددوا الامريكان داخل حدودهم
هذا الراي بتعارضه دول اخرى مثل الصين
وروسيا ودول في المنطقه مثل الجزائر ودول
اوروبيه مثل ايطاليا لاسباب مختلفه ابسطها
الخوف من توابع العدوان فوضى انفلات امني
هجرات جماعيه للاجئين ستغرق بعد هذه الدول
فراغ امني تنتعش فيه الجماعات المتطرفه
الى اخ ثم ان بعض هذه الدول بيشكك من جدوى
التدخل العسكري اصلا في النيجر مش بس لانه
في حاله شهيره حصلت في 2011 و2012 في
ليبيا وادى الى ماسي لقاره افريقيا كلها
ولكن خوفا ايضا مما قد يجري في النيجر
بسبب طبيعه النيجر بلد ضخم متنوع الاعراق
بازوم الرئيس محمد بازون اللي هم الدول دي
بترغب في اعادته للسلطه لما نجح في 2021
نجح بنسبه 56% من الاصوات وحتى هذه اللحظه
ليس من الواضح مقدار الدعم الذي يمكن ان
تقدمه الجماعات المختلفه لبازوم او للدول
اللي عاوزه تدعمه والقوى والاعراق
والقبائل التي سوف تدعم الجماعات
الانقلابيه التي يبدو انها تحظى ببعض
الدعم الشعبي هناك ماذا سوف يحدث لننتظر
ونرى ويكون لنا مع منطقه الساحل ومشاكل
قاره افريقيا حلقات اخرى باذن الله نشكركم
والى